c'est un thème bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors le gouvernement
annonçait le plan de déconfinement
partir du 11 mai plusieurs virologues
belges estiment qu'il arrive trop tôt ce
plan partagez vous cet avis pour
l'instant ce qui est nécessaire et le
gouvernement l'a bien précisé sais que
c'est un plan quelques unes des
propositions
cette proposition peut à tout moment
tomber revenir en arrière être modulée
en fonction des circonstances
le 4 mai d'ailleurs puisque c'est la
première partie des merceries de manière
à faciliter la confection des masques le
11 mai qu'on voulait très bien dit ce
sont les comex
tout ceci peut très bien être postposée
une semaine ou deux si le nombre
d'hospitalisations le nombre alors
sophie ville messin la première ministre
belge s'est appuyé sur le nombre de
décès pour organiser le déconfinement
alors que les virologues conseil de
s'appuyer sur le nombre de nouvelles
admissions admission à l'hôpital c'est
un chiffre qui n'a pas diminué depuis
une semaine
le chiffre d admission pompe aux autres
lots des 200 patients par jour et par le
chiffre miracle on aimerait le voir aux
environs de 100 à 150 patients et c'est
un des points qui pourraient faire
varier à la réouverture des différents
commerces et autres quoi causer
alors on vient de le dire une reprise
progressive des commerces des écoles qui
devrait rouvrir respectivement les 11 et
18 mai prochain des mesures pour
l'instant qui ne sont pas final on va
dire est-ce que vous pensez que au vu de
la situation la première ministre belge
peu rétro pédaler et changer justement
son plan de déconfinement je pense que
ce sera douloureux certainement ça ne
sera pas facile à faire mais dans la
population
mais durant l'exposé que la première
ministre a fait elle a répétée de
multiples fois que ceci était le plan
proposé mais que ce plan peut être
modifié et je vois mal dans le contexte
actuel
comment ceci ne serait pas le cas si les
indicateurs ne sont pas suffisants pour
monter que le système de santé et prêt à
être suffisamment apte à accueillir le
nouveau patient en cas de reprise de
l'épidémie lorsque la distance il
distend ciment social sera alors vous
l'avez sûrement suivi la question des
masques a suscité beaucoup de débats en
france qu'en est-il en belgique
une des voies là des recommandations du
gouvernement c'est le port du masque
obligatoire dans les transports en
commun à partir du 4 mai pour les plus
de 12 ans est ce que vous êtes vous avez
suffisamment de masques en mai j comment
ça va se mettre en place
tu portes la population à cette non
demandeuses le gouvernement avait
concocté par la population n'était pas
utile éventuellement même péjoratif et
est nuisible
je pense que le gouvernement applique
convaincu que en dehors de l'om est
effectivement ça sert à rien beaucoup
d'autres instances ont changé leur point
de vue et maintenant ils présentent très
clairement le basque comme étant un
point additionnel se laver les mains
attention quand on touche au gardien
extensivement sociale mais en addition
de masques joue un rôle alors qu'elles
masquent le basque en tissu normalement
réservé ont toujours des masques
chirurgicaux pour le corps médical et
masque en tissu qui seront distribués
soit par le gouvernement soit par les
structures locales de type comme une
soit au niveau des différents profession
il faut certainement l'aliment de ces
différentes forces pour avoir assez de
masques il est basque bien sûr que l'on
peut faire chez soi à domicile reste la
question de manque de professeurs lui
par la convergence de différentes
épreuves
dernière question très rapidement
docteur van laethem on se souvient d'un
gaz à sion mondiale de la santé qui
avait préconisé aux états de tester
tester tester les populations pour
essayer d'endiguer le plus possible la
pandémie du coronavirus qu'en est-il en
belgique
des tests alors pour l'instant nous
avons à peu près petitesse de paix par
jour
le corps scientifique qui a conseillé le
gouvernement a demandé à voir au moins
vaccin vite et ce par jour qui peut
monter jusqu'à 45 milles ce sera
effectivement un défi parce que pour
l'instant ce n'est pas réalisable
ce sera un défi de le faire dans les
huit ou quinze jours in ten je pense que
très clairement c'est nécessaire tout
comme le pressing d'ailleurs été lui
aussi institutionnaliser merci beaucoup
à yves van laethem d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin responsable channel clinique au
chu saint-pierre à bruxelles